[Music]
after matchmaking for a couple of days
during the outbreak global event I found
that there are a lot of people that
really aren't understanding the
modifiers and how to take advantage of
them
it made me realize that through the rush
of me trying to get the last video out
on time I did leave out a little bit of
detail that could further enhance your
experience in the global events this
time we'll be leaving out the basics
covered in the last video and instead
going into a little bit more depth
showing some build options based on the
modifiers for each of the three
remaining events and also some tips on
how to unlock the mast commendations the
builder recommend will be based off the
beginner guide builds have shown
previously so regardless of where you're
at in the game so far you should be able
to throw something together with the
basic pieces shown in each video in
order to take advantage of the modifiers
alternatively if you're a bit further
along and have the gear to make a more
optimized build it'll give you an idea
of what abilities and talents you should
be aiming for all builds mentioned will
be linked in the description below the
next global event is a salt this event
contains two of the best classified sets
in the game strikers and reclaimer the
salt revolves around getting up close
and personal with the npcs being close
will give you a huge damage buff however
with the crucial and major modifiers
which are optional within the assault
playlist missions being at range from
the enemies and Ally agents will have
the NPC's doing more damage to you this
global modifier actually makes
everything in the game easier but the
crucial and assault force you into
changing up your playstyle
if you're a player that prefers to sit
back you'll struggle particularly in a
team situation sniper NPCs can be a bit
of a threat if you're far from your
allies a lot of the time they will drop
you on one hit the Builder recommend is
a d3 if NC tank built for a variation of
this this build excels at being up close
and even with the team that has no idea
what they're doing you'll comfortably be
able to carry them through you'll be
able to mow down close range NPCs
gaining a massive amount of health on
kill and even if the NPC's are at range
you have the shield to protect you
they're running with the team or with
randoms I recommend running the d5 is
your second skill because you'll also
end up being the team Reviver when
things go wrong in the previous assault
global event I actually found it easier
and faster
solo through the missions because the
enemies were even weaker and fewer and
number and would match made groups I
found I was spending more time keeping
allies alive than shooting at the NPC's
in turn making the build less effective
a couple of the masks in this event
required a run with a team as you can
see here I didn't manage to collect them
all last time remember to make sure that
all of the conditions have been set up
properly in order to obtain the masks
the first mask
haki is fairly easy to obtain kill 500
LMB and the assault playlist with the
crucial or major modifier activated you
don't really have to hunt this one down
just play the game as usual and you'll
eventually get this the second mask
happy requires you to complete each
assault playlist mission without agent
or agents being downed most of these
missions can be so load but the Falcon
lost incursion can be tricky on your own
so in order to unlock this known and the
team can be downed personally I'll be
attempting to solo this but if you were
to get a group together let the others
know what you're trying to achieve the
third mask and assault is picky although
this must be running groups this is
actually a little bit easier than masks
to being downed or wiping will not fail
the commendation you just have to make
sure that no one in the group is running
mythical skills it'll take a bit longer
than usual to complete the incursion but
there are checkpoints every few waves so
just take your time and make your way
through them
the third global event is strike this is
all about stacker and explosions but
mainly Steger get too close to a down to
MPC the explosion will stagger you take
too many hits you will explode and
stagger get too close to an ally when
they explode from damage and your
stagger this is probably the least fun
global event to play out of the four but
working through it will give you the
opportunity to collect two of the best
solo player classified sets in the game
nomads and d3 fnc and also the much
loved and loathed pvp set predators mark
the global modifier has NPCs exploding
after being killed so try and avoid
getting too close the pre-emptive and
tactical modifiers will have agents who
sustain too much damage triggering off
an explosion - and have to close to
another agent they will receive
increased damage from the explosion it
is possible to create chain reactions
among the NPC explosions but the most
memorable thing about this event is the
stagger because your allies are
exploding left right and center as best
to keep distance from them if anything
just to decrease the amount of stagger
time you'll be facing the two builds
around most during this event was nomads
and d3 if NC the main reason being that
the amount of explosions going on does
have an impact on your health over time
so you want a builder can really look
after itself again I would probably
favor the d3 build as a solo player
because the shield can stop a lot of the
damage you're taking minimizing yourself
explosions but try not to get too close
if you're good with using cover and
would like a bit more range go for the
Nomad build on the positive side the
masks in this event are really easy to
obtain they can all be gathered running
Solo masks one rider is awarded to you
when you complete any strike activity
without taking any explosion damage the
best way to do this is to sit back with
a range to a skill power build and
slowly make your way through the mission
if you take any damage fall back until
your damage bar drops down mask to
classic requires you to run through a
mission in a group and not take any
explosion damage from an ally you can
easily choose this commendation by
running through the mission solo it
doesn't matter if you take explosion
damage from yourself so just fight your
way through to the end
killing all enemies apart from the boss
once you're there put yourself somewhere
safe and start matchmaking as soon as
someone joins you finish off the boss
both you and the joining agent will
receive a commendation and the mask mask
three jungle it's a little bit more
grindy you'll need patience for this one
you need to kill a total of 150 Ryker
bosses these can be obtained from
anywhere dark zone light zone bosses and
missions but if you're willing to sit
back and grind for it the fastest way is
to equip yourself with a full firearms
build and a bolt-action sniper change
over the world Tier one and run through
to the end of Lexington event center
when you get to the final boss room
you'll see lhara garret and two heavies
standing on stage if you can one-shot
Lara before they're alerted to your
presence this will count as a Ryker boss
skill you can then that the heavies kill
you and rinse and repeat please note if
you don't manage to kill her in one shot
or you miss let the heavies kill you and
try again
this is boring and will probably take
you about an hour to complete so just do
a few at a time or maybe leave it until
the end of the event when you may have
already acquired a few boss kills global
event 4 is ambush the idea here is to
not move the global modifier is agents
deal increased damage while stationary
this sounds a little boring but with the
right build it can actually be a lot of
fun the cover and strategic modifiers
further add to this by damage over time
when moving and even more damage over
time when close to allies this isn't as
difficult as it sounds when you think of
increased damage while not moving two
builds come to mind a sniper built or
better yet a damage dealing skill power
build tactician x' your seeker minds and
bfb sticky bombs are in their element
here using this all of the content is
easy the damage you can get out of
skills during this event is massive I
was never a huge fan of sticky bombs
before this event now I'll always have a
built safe to my loadout
this event has some of the coolest
looking masks much like strike these are
quite easy to achieve mask 1 cage kill
400 enemies while stationary you won't
have to do anything different for this
one just run through this event normally
and you'll have acquired and no time
masks to bug kill 100 enemies whilst
moving again quite easy you may want to
switch up builds to something that can
take a bit more damage but just make
sure you're moving mask 3 haze kill 250
enemies whilst near an ally and
strategic ambush you'll find this easier
with a friend using a healer built to
counter the added damage but even in
matchmaking it's perfectly achievable
you may just find a few people get upset
with you for the extra damage they're
receiving I would have loved to cover
more of the combinations and how you can
complete them but due to the very small
amount of time in between each global
event this month I wanted to get this
out before GE 2 started as I said
earlier the recommendations here are
based on beginner builds to give players
new to these events a good place to
start so if you have more in the way of
gear you can still take the same
principles here and apply them to your
own build if there are further questions
on the global events that I might be
able to quickly answer let me know in
the comments below otherwise thanks for
watching and see you next one Cheers
[Music]